today we are doing the number two 777 7
7 7 8 8 8 8 8 9 9 so I guess if you want
to split that up two hundred seventy
seven trillion seven hundred and seventy
seven billion seven hundred and seventy
eight million eight hundred eighty eight
thousand eight hundred and ninety nine
this is a a record-breaking number when
it comes to the multiplication
assistance of a number so we'll do a
smaller one just to get a handle on it
we'd like to give me a small I don't
know like three or four digit number
would you like ready oh I always regret
asking you this 54:28 right so the first
thing we do is we multiply all the
digits together so five and two is gonna
give us ten four and eight to give us 32
so it's gonna be 320 and then we
continue we multiply all the digits
together
now there's a zero so zero so you made
it two steps before we hit a one digit
number and if we have any one digit
number you just you can't multiply the
digits anymore and you stop so the
question is I'm so disappointed yeah
can I have another try did you want
another go yeah let's try this it's not
called persistence for nothing what
would you like see where you went wrong
brady is a 502 spells doom because
that's gonna chuck a 0 on the end
straight away so don't make that mistake
again three to six nice you going for
primes look at you okay let's see how
that goes so that six sevens which is 42
someone will correct me if I'm wrong
four times two is gonna give us eight
and then we're stuck two steps at home
if you want try and pick a number see if
you can beat Brady's current record of 2
so how long do you reckon this one goes
for your big number yeah big number what
do you what do you think we're gonna get
out of that one have yeah what do you
reckon dude you've already told me it's
a record holder that's right but because
you're willing to do it for me now makes
me think it's not crazy big whether by
shied away from a crazy-big calculation
so I'm gonna go for something
surprisingly smaller I'm gonna go for
like 10 10
my calculator out two times seven equals
there's one seven two four nine nine six
times six times two oh okay so now we're
down to four times three times eight
what's very exciting about this is I've
never actually checked this this is the
first time I've actually and now I'm
feeling a little nervous like that's the
level of preparation yet on numberphile
how much prep I put into these videos
pretty is like what numbers are you into
currently I like are kind of interested
in this one two seven seven times 54 5
times 4 is 20 is 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
Oh 11 and that's the correct answer
thank goodness it has a persistence of
11 which is the current world record for
multiplication persistence of a number
other numbers equaled the record but
this is the shortest number with the
biggest currently no and persistence and
so that is the current champion hang on
so you're with no limit on the number of
digits no-knock is about managers
everyone and often in these videos I say
I went away and I programmed a thing and
then I calculate it and I found this I
found that i have not programmed this
yet because as you may have those little
underprepared today I haven't coded it
up but we could should we do it live do
me do it do it cuz I always say I code
something and I find them let's code
something let's find it
I'll get my laptop so funny story last
week my keyboard stopped working and the
trackpad on my laptop which is a bit
awkward okay so first things first we're
gonna set something going which is going
to do this process over and over and
over again but we want it to stop once
it gets to a thing which is only one
okay so this is gonna take some number
and the first thing we're gonna say is
if the
the length of the number of digits to
the string and so the great thing about
n isn't it's not only a number when we
care about digits I'm going to turn it
into a string that goes from being like
a number represented in binary or
whatever base to just being the base ten
digits in a string and if the length of
that string equals one then we're done
right we're at the very end of the thing
right so that's at that point print
whatever n is and then finish so return
I don't know like done all right that's
just gonna tell it you know your job
here is done
okay otherwise we need to multiply
together all the digits digits equals
with two as a list I for I in the string
version of the number right so they're
turning into a string of digits and then
it's taking out each one individually
all but we want them as as numbers so
let's turn them back into numbers so
bizarrely I'm turning it into digits as
a string then taking out each one
separately then turning them back into
numbers right which is kind of because
this is a base-10 thing one of the sad
things about stuff like this is its base
specific so now we've got all the digits
for J I'm just using J is the
placeholder in digits so now we want to
multiply them all together okay you know
let's have current result result equals
one to start with and then each time
result equals result multiplied by that
digit and you can do x equals just means
make it equal to this times Jack whoops
J okay I think that's it and that's
gonna give us a new result but then
we've got to repeat the process so this
is where we can cheat and I haven't
genuinely haven't tried coding this
before so I don't know if this is going
to work I'm going to try and get
recursive and then put that new result
into the same function so if it's one
long it'll stop otherwise it'll multiply
all the digits together and then put it
back into the beginning and it will
keep repeating through this process and
you know what let's make it print the
result each time so we get we get to see
them all as it as it loops through and
then when it hits here it'll stop and
say done okay that can't go wrong that's
fine I really should have checked this
in advance okay
copy I'm just gonna fire up terminal
okay so what I'm actually gonna do this
is the laziest way to run something
literally paste it into terminal let's
do the persistence of three to seven
which is the second one you said 42
eight and then eight forever right and
so it's donate twice and then going
we're out okay I couldn't fix the code
to not get the the last one twice I just
changed where the check is so actually
what I could have done is have another
check in here so I don't print the
result and then print it again before
stopping I could put the check in but
I'm not gonna nodes it fit for purpose
alright for a first pass it's fine
and then the very first one let's just
check the first one just to make sure
I've messed this up five four two eight
it goes to three twenty goes to zero
right and now the ultimate test can it
handle two six seven 6/8 two nines there
we go right so and that's that's so much
quicker right so it's now spat out
exactly these all the way down and then
it stops doesn't give us a number are do
we want like a do we want a number of
steps at the end number of steps okay
okay I ready will cut this out and put
it on the second channel too one two
three four five six loops 1 2 3 4 5 6 1
2 yeah total steps 11 okay right so now
we can put a number in and instantly we
get everything we could no longer print
every single step along the way it's
kind of fun to see and we get the total
number steps so Brady let's put on what
would you like you know let's put put as
we just mash it for a while and see what
we get no cuz you can be strategic ah
you're right to put a 5
just put in a bunch put in 59 $15.99 two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14 15 which is just nine to the
15 and I put in another 10 Oh another
ten nine yep
well let's just see if that one works
two steps oh because we got the zero in
the answer next time but what I can do
in your in terminal just push up you get
the previous one stuck a few more 9s on
the end two steps now what if we um put
in eight instead two steps what about
what about the string you used like at
the current record holder
yeah but put a three on the front I love
it okay so 3 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 9
9 ah brilliant I love like I love you
thinking ready and 2 steps so it's zero
zeros are a lamb boom hit a zero you're
out this is minesweeper but for number
searches okay
so this is what I would do I would now
play with this for a while and it seems
to be whenever you put in some random
string of numbers and boom right because
it was a zero the next one it's gone
would need to be more strategic what
about all the digits of pi all of them
get cracking on that three eight one
four one five nine two six five I figure
that's that's enough - Wow
11 seems a lot more impressive all of a
sudden no wonder it's the world record
so does this mean that you could set up
a program that would just put every
number in one after another and just
leave it you know leave it for an hour
or two so what we've done now is we've
built the basics of checking next we
want to build something to do the search
so we could just get something to
generate random numbers of a certain
size shove them in and send us an email
if it gets a good one the next step
would be to be strategic about what
numbers we were putting in because
already you realized don't put it in a 5
you put in a 5 it's not gonna work so we
could create a search which doesn't put
in fives
doesn't put in any combination we know
will definitely give us zero and
actually we can get even smarter than
that because if we're looking for the
smallest number that it works for it
doesn't matter what order the digits are
in so in fact all the current record
holders the shortest number of digits
for different persistence values so
there's a record holder for 10 and for 9
and so on they're always the digits
worries in ascending order because you
want the smallest number with those
digits so in fact you don't have to
search for shuffled around versions you
just need that set of digits in that
order and then there's other things so
for example this one here we'll use your
first one you put in five four to eight
that's going to give you exactly the
same result as first of all you could
have put in two four five eight which is
smaller but actually two times four is
going to give you eight so you could
actually have just put in five eight
eight that's going to give you exactly
the same sequence as that and it's
smaller so if all you care about are the
smallest possible values for that
sequence of persistence afterwards
multiplication persistence then you
never want to have a 2 and a 4 you never
want to have two threes because I could
be a 9 you never want a 5 at all in fact
you only ever end up with a few small
numbers at the beginning never more than
1 2 never more than 1 3 never more than
1/4 I think and then all sevens eights
and nines for the rest of it so we could
reduce our search space dramatically
with a little bit of logic the current
search has gone as far as 233 digits so
if you do code it up you've got to start
searching from 233 it's not gonna be
smaller than that we've already checked
and it's currently the conjecture is you
would never be 11 so if people want to
have a go I mean I'm always one to give
it a go see if you can write some code
see if it does a clever search and you
know it would be a major breakthrough if
someone could find a number with a
multiplication of assistance of 12 will
you be the person to make that major
breakthrough certainly the sorts of
people who cracked
tough nuts are those who think outside
the box
creative thinkers people who don't
follow the flock and brilliant wants to
make you that type of person their
courses quizzes puzzles like the ones
you see on the screen at the moment
they're carefully crafted to mould
people into smarter thinkers not
memorizers not people who just know all
the equations and how to pass a test but
problem solvers people with better wired
brains if you'd like to find out more
about brilliant what they're making and
how they might help you go to brilliant
org slash numberphile there's free stuff
on their site but that slash numberphile
URL that'll get you 20% of one of their
premium memberships and it'll also let
them know you came from here
[Music]